according to the media research center
good friends of ours it has been ready
259 days
since the network newscasts of record
have uttered the words hunter biden 259
days thankfully the wall street journal
is on the case publishing a new article
today titled prosecutors advance tax
probe of hunter biden it claims that the
hunter biden probe is gaining steam
when it comes to his taxes quote
prosecutors have asked questions about
several companies associated with hunter
biden and are examining whether he moved
funds in a way to obscure his tax
liability
we've got new details regarding
kickbacks hunter allegedly received like
the time a company led by a kazakhstani
banker
remember kazakhstan
wired 142 grand to hunter's consulting
firm
that money was later used to buy hunter
an electric sports car
a fisker
and hunter later traded it for a silver
porsche
because nobody in the biden family
drives electric of course that's just
for you to do
sounds sketchy to me but
something feels weird about this whole
probe right
do you guys get the feeling that this
whole tax investigation is just a red
herring or a diversion away from more
serious crimes
you know charges that could implicate
other members of the family like the big
guy
jim trustee is a former
doj prosecutor and he joins us tonight
all right jim what gives you the
impression that there's a little bit of
a cleanup job going on at biden's
department of justice
well you know the starting point is that
it was the defense attorneys for hunter
several months ago that leaked out this
notion that he had some tax issues that
he had to clean up and i thought even at
the time that sounds like a really good
defense attorney euphemism for much
bigger problems i mean it's kind of like
al capone's lawyer say well he's got a
little tax issue don't worry about the
valentine's day massacre so i think from
the get-go all the public reporting
we've seen about the laptop about wire
transfers from russian oligarchs
kazakhstan everywhere else it all smells
like a much bigger case than tax evasion
it smells like possibly foreign agent
registration act foreign corrupt
practices act money laundering i mean
big weighty federal charges that are
really indicative of a pay-for-play kind
of scheme and so maybe the evidence
isn't there but if the evidence is there
and you have these trial balloons about
tax cases coming out it smells like
something where there's going to be a
little bit of doj collusion to come to a
very soft ending in this case would
hunter have to go to prison for a tax
beef
well not not necessarily i mean there's
room for prosecutors to be a little
creative it's harder when you're a
federal prosecutor than a state
prosecutor believe it or not because of
things like mandatory sentences and
sentencing guidelines that are driven by
loss amount in other words all those
dollars stack up to higher exposure for
him but there's ways to do it and that's
what i'm a little nervous about again i
don't have proof of this at all but the
way it's been dragging on the way it's
been very quiet the way the trial
balloon came out i could see kind of a
quiet friday afternoon announcement that
hunter has a misdemeanor plea that he's
got to enter or a deferred prosecution
agreement there are ways to either cap
it or eliminate the ability of any uh
judge to put prison on the table wow so
hunter after all this could end up with
no jail time
do you think that federal prosecutors i
know this is coming out of delaware are
getting pressure
from maine justice
yeah no way to know i guess the way i
would phrase it jesse is like there may
not be pressure but i'm not in love with
how the fbi has conducted itself under
chris wray i don't see a big difference
between the politicization that they had
with comey
and take it and take into account like
doing federal search warrants for
diaries i mean that's unheard of so i'm
a little nervous that the investigating
agency here has a little political edge
to it when it comes to the leadership
the us attorney has kept their position
because of this investigation which is
actually not unheard of that's typical
when there's a potential conflict of
interest but i i think it's a real
integrity test for the attorney general
because that's the guy that's going to
have to sign off on anything whether
it's a very strong indictment a
non-prosecution agreement a deferred
prosecution agreement a soft plea giving
him you know basically no jail any of
those things are going to make their way
up to the attorney general and and boy
it's a huge integrity test i think
unlike anything we've seen in
presidential history
well we've had a guest on last week who
told us they thought that hunter was
going to go to prison for a while unless
his dad pardoned him and now you're
saying that he might get away scot-free
and
i don't know what to think i'm just
wondering where that diamond is that
that chinese tycoon gave him
we'll have to keep following where the
leads take us thank you very much
trustee all right see jess hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else